[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the jury begins to deliberate the fate
of kyle rittenhouse when you agreed upon
your verdict have it signed and dated by
the presiding juror as to each count and
all of you return with the verdict to
the court we're now on verdict watch for
the accused kenosha shooter and the
death of ahmad armory is there anything
law enforcement or ems could have done
to save his life at the scene
i don't think so no the medical examiner
takes the stand in the racially charged
case plus a former trump aide turns
himself in to the fbi
how long could steve bannon be behind
bars for criminal contempt of congress
and later controversial broadcaster alex
jones found guilty by default in a
defamation lawsuit why this means a
victory for the families of sandy hook
school shooting victims law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross in for brian
buckmeyer who's in georgia covering the
trial of the men accused of killing a
mod arbory joining me here in new york
is co-host terry austin and terry we
begin with a verdict watch in wisconsin
where a jury is deliberating the fate of
kyle rittenhouse
eighteen-year-old ridden house faces
five charges including reckless murder
and attempted murder in connection with
the august 25 2020 shooting in kenosha
wisconsin two men joseph rosenbaum and
anthony hoover died as a result of the
shootings gage grushquatz was shot and
wounded but survived rittenhouse's team
argues the defendant was acting in
self-defense that night on monday a set
of 12 jurors began deliberation inside
the kenosha county courthouse that's
where law and crime's anjanet levy joins
us now anjanet
brian the day started with that final
jury of seven women and
five men being determined those
alternate jurors were selected and we
want to show you a little bit of how
that process unfolded now the numbers
used to identify those jurors were
placed in a tumbler and kyle rittenhouse
reached in and pulled out six numbers
that determined which jurors would be
the alternates and they remained at the
courthouse in case they were needed the
jurors asked for extra copies of the
jury instructions they will have to
decide whether kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense or committed crimes when he
shot and killed joseph rosenbaum and
anthony huber and wounded gage gross
croods judge bruce schroeder gave the
jury a final instruction after closing
arguments
you will disregard the claims or
opinions of any other person or news
media or social networking site you will
pay no heed to the opinions of anyone
even the president of the united states
or the president before him
and you don't hear references to the
president and the former president of
the united states in murder trials very
often now outside of the courthouse here
in kenosha county
about 50 people have gathered there are
supporters of kyle rittenhouse along
with protesters black lives matter
protesters among them is the uncle of
jacob blake he is the man who was shot
by police in august of 2020 here in
kenosha and it sparked the unrest where
kyle rittenhouse shot three people
it's about right and wrong this isn't
about the second amendment this is a
murder case little jake's high hero baby
just like
anthony and jojo are
his mind is just always up his spirit is
always up if his body ever catches back
up to him it's going to be a hell of a
miracle
now as i mentioned there were also
supporters of kyle renton house here
among them the mccluskies you may recall
they are the couple from missouri who
pointed their guns at protesters outside
of their home in the summer of 2020 they
were charged and later pleaded guilty to
a misdemeanor charge and they were later
pardoned by the governor of missouri
we think this is a political
prosecution we think we are politically
persecuted and we're standing up for the
rights of others
now mark and patricia mccloskey say
they've actually not met kyle
rittenhouse and they have not been in
the courthouse and i should mention that
mark mccluskey is running for senate u.s
senator from missouri brian okay thanks
answer that let's bring in now co-host
terry austin and criminal defense
attorney roger foley roger a large part
of this case has to do with self-defense
and whether mr rittenhouse can use that
defense if he in fact provoked the
confrontation as the prosecution argues
how does that sort out for you roger
well that's the question that that
that's what the prosecution led to it
towards the end of the case i think the
case wasn't going very well for them and
they realized that if they came up with
the argument that if written house
provoked
the the argument then self-defense would
not be a claim that he'd be able to use
uh in this case so that's the question
will the jury believe that he provoked
this incident or initiated this incident
or was it self-defense where he was
trying to run away right and terry the
jury is already asking for clarification
on some important legal standards what's
the significance of that
i think it's very significant brian they
asked for the first six pages of the
jury instructions and we know they were
long and convoluted they wanted to
understand the definition of
self-defense provocation and they
specifically wanted to know what the
charges were as related to rosenbaum i
think we're going to get a split verdict
here overall i think as far as rosenbaum
is concerned they're going to believe
that self-defense but as far as some of
the others i'm not so sure i think
recklessness as far as mcginnis is
concerned either weighing on huber
engage in all of these if it's split
there is significant jail time so i
think that's what's going to happen and
angenette the rittenhouse family is
there what are you hearing from them
i spoke with dave hancock he has been
serving as the spokesperson for the
rittenhouse family and he feels you know
good about the case they believe this
should be an acquittal on all counts
they believe kyle acted in self-defense
and they are feeling pretty good about
things and hopeful right now okay thanks
to all of you still ahead on law and
crime daily a one-time top trump adviser
surrenders to the fbi on criminal
contempt of congress charges
but first the trial of the men accused
of killing a mod arbory law on crime's
brian buckmeyer is in georgia with the
trial's newest developments
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gavel coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
return now to georgia where the state
has rusted its case in the trial of the
three men accused of killing ahmad aubry
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryant face
several charges in the death of arbory
including malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault in february 2020
gregory and travis mcmichael tailed
aubry in their pickup truck as he went
for a jog travis mcmichael eventually
shot arbory claiming self-defense brian
followed along in his own pickup truck
and recorded the incident in a now
infamous viral video at the time of the
shooting arbory was unarmed and jogging
near his brunswick georgia home all
three defendants face life in prison if
convicted our own brian buckmeyer has
been covering the trial from glenn
county georgia and that's where he joins
us now with the latest brian
yes brian ross day eight of the trial
for the death of ahmad arbory against
the mcmichaels and brian began with more
testimony about the investigation into
the case and some medical testimony from
a pathologist
officer richard dial of the gbi
testified giving more insight to the
events through drone video of the routes
taken both by william bryan and ahmad
aubry based on the testimony or the
evidence collected from william bryant
medical examiner edmund donahue
testifying in the trial for the death of
a mod aubry gave the jury graphic photos
of a mod aubry's body after his death we
also heard that ahmad's arms were 23 and
26 inches in length from the armpits to
the hand and based on the wounds a
muzzle
to target estimation was three to four
feet but after reviewing the
uh video he estimates that the distance
from the target to muzzle was three to
twenty inches showing that ahmad aubrey
was close uh to grabbing the gun but was
shot earlier than that don who also
showed us injuries of the wrist and
torso and speculated that the angle
could show that the shot came at him
from a distance close by for striking
his wrist than his center of mass
donahue ultimately said the injuries
could have two interpretations
it was my opinion that the shot to the
center of the chest
and the grazing gunshot wound to the
wrist occurred at the same time
meaning that the
hand was in front of the chest and was
struck first and then
it entered the body
it was my opinion that the second shot
was a complete miss
and did not enter
any part of the body
and that the third shot involved the
left chest and axilla they happened at
the same time
would that be
consistent with someone
pushing a shotgun away from them
it could be yes
is it also consistent with someone maybe
grabbing the shotgun
it could be yes
let's bring back co-host terry austin
and roger foley roger the prosecution
introduced as brian just told us a
number of graphic photos what's the
thinking about that and is there a
danger it could have a backlash with the
jury
i don't know that it would have a
backlash i mean obviously this was a a a
scene where someone lost their life
so it's important that the jury actually
see this information and see the the
penetration from the bullet and and all
the discussions regarding where the two
gentlemen were standing in the street
when it occurred and whether or not it
was a defensive wound or whether it was
an aggressive wound but i think it was
necessary for the prosecution to show
all of this evidence in order to get a
conviction and terry the medical
examiner said he edited his autopsy
report after viewing the video do you
think that's problematic for the
prosecution
it is a problem brian for the
prosecution and that's why she attacked
it head on she was trying to say look he
edited his report because he saw the
video and as brian buckmeyer said the
muzzle to target distance it changed
from three to four feet to three to 20
inches that's a big difference and it
matters because of this that
self-defense claim the closer it is the
more that they're going to be able to
show that it was not uh self-or that it
was self-defense the further away it's
going to be harder to show the
self-defense so it's an important issue
and that's why i think the prosecution
was trying to make sure the jury knew
that the medical examiner correctly
edited the report and brian the
prosecution has now arrested they
arrested on tuesday how does the case
look for them and what do we expect from
the defense now
so the prosecution's case led us through
the whole event first with the tragedy
of seeing ahmad aubrey's body
some of the testimony from both glenn
county officers and gbi officers and
then ended with this drone video from
officer dial of the gbi really showing
us the route that ahmad army would have
taken along with that of uh william
bryant based on the testimony one of the
bigger things that i saw for the medical
examiner were the spurting of blood that
we saw when a mod
and uh trappist and michael are fighting
with the gun so we know that it was shot
first and then uh struggle afterwards
now they've rested and it appears that
it's up to the defense as to whether or
not they're gonna put on a case i would
guess based on the opening statement
that travis and michael may end up
testifying all right well that'll be
fascinating thanks all coming up on law
and crime daily a win for the families
of the sandy hook school shooting
victims the latest in their defamation
suit against far-right radio host alex
jones
plus steve bannon turns himself in to
the fbi
before appearing in front of the federal
judge what's next for the former top
trump aide after the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
former trump aide and advisor steve
bannon is set to be arraigned this week
on charges of contempt of congress in
connection to the january 6
investigation
bannon was indicted on friday after he
defied a subpoena to submit his records
relating to the january 6 insurrection
at the u.s capitol he also ignored a
call to appear in front of the so-called
january 6 committee and testify about
what he did that day and before bannon
turned himself into the fbi on monday
and briefly appeared before a federal
judge he faces two counts for refusing
to testify or turn over documents
carrying a maximum penalty of one year
in jail and up to one hundred thousand
dollars in fines for each count all this
comes as an appeals court temporarily
cited with former president trump
allowing his january 6 related records
to remain sealed for now oral arguments
in that case are set for november 30th
let's bring in roger foley and terry
austin
roger bannon claims he didn't turn over
the documents because he was covered by
executive privilege under former
president trump but ben left the trump
administration in 2017 so how does
something he did in 2020 or 2021 apply
how does that claim hold any water
i i don't think it holds any water i
think steve bannon is going to have some
difficulty here had this incident
happened in 2016 or 2017 when he was
part of the administration then i think
that that he would have a valid argument
but considering this stuff happened
january 6th what 2020 um i i think he's
got big problems in regards to this and
i think ultimately he's going to have to
turn over this information that they've
requested of them
and terry mark meadows trump's former
chief of staff also missed a deadline to
answer questions
the bannon indictment seems to send a
pretty strong message to mr meadows
doesn't it
i think it does and i think mark meadows
has a reputation that he wants to defend
he really does not want to antagonize
the committee and we've seen that bannon
absolutely has antagonized that
committee and we know that mark meadows
doesn't want to be held in contempt
based on his actions he seems as though
he wants to have conversations he wants
to have a compromise and i'm certain
that he doesn't want to serve jail time
now we already know that they have
signaled that they will be talking to
each other mark meadows really is in a
better position because at the time he
actually was a part of the
administration and he can claim
the executive privilege or at least try
to so he has a little bit of leverage
there and i think because of that the
committee is going to negotiate with him
in good faith try to reach out a
compromise maybe produce some documents
and maybe even sit for a deposition so
mark meadows is going to try to work out
all of these issues prior to being held
in contempt or put in jail and roger and
terry steve bennett seems to be enjoying
the attention
i i think he is and i think he wants to
make the point as he said in his press
clip this is going to be the toughest
misdemeanor i'm not going to lay down
i'm going to fight the fight and i'm
going to have my day in court and this
is unprecedented right we've never had
this in our nation's history so it is an
opportunity for him to speak his mind
and say because does congress really
have the power
in regards to what they're asking him
for because they're trying to say that
he helped incite this whether or not
that's true we'll find out but i'm
looking forward to it guys absolutely
okay on to more federal news now as
potential jurors are screened in the
trial of socialite gilain maxwell she's
accused of aiding jeffrey epstein in
abusing underage girls 59 year old
maxwell is charged with six felonies
including conspiracy to entice minors to
engage in illegal sex acts and
transportation of a minor to engage in
an illegal sex act these charges stem
from a relationship with longtime
companion epstein who was arrested on
federal charges of sex trafficking in
2019. federal prosecutors say maxwell
helped epstein groom girls as young as
14 years old for sexual abuse and
sometimes participated herself in the
abuse maxwell pleaded not guilty to all
the charges and has been held without
bond in a brooklyn jail this week a
federal judge will question potential
jurors until 50 people are qualified on
the first day of trial the jury will be
whittled down to 12 journals with six
alternates the trial is set to begin on
november 29th
when we come back controversial radio
host alec jones found liable the sandy
hook defamation case what's next for the
infowars host and what this could mean
for the families of the sandy hook
school shooting victims
and welcome back turning now to a legal
victory for the families of the sandy
hook school shooting victims as the
judge finds controversial broadcast host
alex jones liable in a defamation
lawsuit
on monday connecticut's superior court
judge cited jones non-compliance with
the discovery process of the case saying
jones was liable by default after he
refused to hand over financial and
analytical data at the request of the
sandy hook families the case stems from
comments made by the infowars host
calling the 2012 school shooting staged
by actors the sandy hook family's
maintained jones has profited from
conspiracy theories relating to the
shooting jones has since acknowledged
the shooting that killed 20 students and
six staff members was not staged from
here the case will now proceed to a jury
to determine the amount of damages to be
awarded to the families a status
conference in the case is set for
wednesday
roger there was a similar outcome for
jones in a texas case where he also
failed to turn over documents so now all
that's left for the jury really is to
determine how much money right
that's that's correct brian it's just
simply a a trial on damages how much
damage has he inflicted on these
families how much pain has he caused and
how much money does he have to pay um
that that's what ultimately becomes the
question and the jury is going to come
back with probably a big number because
his statements quite frankly were
outrageous they're outrageous to anyone
even as probably his own fans you know
to say that these killings were staged
is just
there's no understanding of why someone
would say something like that and
knowing the detrimental pain that it
causes to a family
and terry what does he have to the
planets have to show now in order to get
damages from jones what do they have to
make to make their case with
well normally they would have to prove
their case and with a defamation case
you'd have to show a false statement a
publication of a false statement you'd
have to show that that statement was
knowingly or negligently made you'd have
to show the harm but here because
there's a default as roger just said all
they have to do is show the damages and
what they can do here is show if there
was emotional distress come in with a
doctor's
invoice showing exactly how much that
was come in and show that there was lost
wages because of the emotional strain
and stress that it took on their lives
so they'd have to document the actual
damages that they incurred but they
don't have to do anything else brian
because that's already been done with
the default judgment all right terry
austin roger foley thank you very much
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you